who are you people and what do you want
with Rachel as much as I'd love to have
a lengthy conversation with you about
Rachel Roth detective I'm afraid there's
no time you found me
I've been exposed so the organization is
sending people to kill us
we have one minute unless we leave right
now or we could stay for one last glass
of champagne no one knows I'm here
I do so does the old woman downstairs
they are everywhere
does this organization work for Rachel's
father is he still looking for her you
could say that yes oh dear my crepes are
burning if you don't give you some
answers I'm gonna eat your face I'm
sorry detective but we have ten seconds
before the final answers come for both
of us what do you want me to reach oh I
do love a good champagne I want some
answers
five four three okay you're coming with
me
wha
Wow
Dick Grayson in the flesh nice to meet
you bro
I'm the new Robin
but you're Robin - I thought you were
Robin
I am it was how many Robins are there
we're sent to the Gotham PD address -
Robin I know these people whoever sent
them - you're still Robin good to
finally talk to you Dick Grayson it's
not possible was helping me it was
turning me into a weapon his weapon but
you can't unlearn what he teaches you
when you can't control everybody is
Charlie we finally have Jason Todd on
Titan's it's time to meet the new Robin
in the future Red Hood I have a really
big theory about how they foreshadow
Red Hood in this episode they sort of
set up a couple plot points that I think
that they can pay off later on or in a
future season when they go full Red Hood
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing a new round of that DC
streaming service giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video so
Jason Todd newly-minted Robin comes to
the rescue of old Robin and in the
trailer for next week's episode we find
out the real reason why he came to find
him is that someone's been sending
pictures of victims tied to Dick Grayson
thinking that he's still Robin there's a
flashback to original Robin going crazy
on someone over the death of his parents
it's implied that the person who seems
like they're back from the grave with
this mask on is Tony Zucco the person
responsible for the death of his parents
in the comics the original story has
stayed largely the same throughout comic
book reboots but Tony Zucco is usually a
mobster trying to extort money from
Hayley's circus when Hayley the owner
refuses to pay up Tony Zucco sabotages
the trapeze rig and when the flying
Grayson's performed their act it kills
his parents the way they set it up in
this footage implies that the whole
crossing the line going too dark that he
talks about going too brutal and why he
left Batman was directly tied to the
hunt for Tony Zucco who it seems like
Robin has bullied was dead this whole
time like it can't be true it there's no
way it could be you because you're
supposed to be dead so maybe he thinks
he killed him and that's part of the
reason why he left Batman like he won't
shut up about how dark things got and
how he left it how he didn't like who he
is turning into maybe thinking that he
killed someone was
event they have a couple funny moments
with Jason Todd meeting Beast Boy and
the rest of the team I thought that you
were Robin there's only supposed to be
one Robin yeah he's the old Robin then
most of the rest of the episode seems
like it's dedicated to them teaming up
Robin and Robin in taking down Tony
Zucco here's where we get to the Red
Hood of it all the really exciting stuff
so I put that clip at the beginning of
this Robin is confronting someone called
dr. Abramson there's no one of that name
in the comics so he's just an original
creation of the TV show he implies that
he's working for Trigon never says the
actual name of the organization that he
works for but I've had this theory for a
while just based on the way the comics
plan out through this Trigon arc is that
there's a scene at the beginning of the
episode where he's cracking eggs one of
them is really bloody
and he just proceeds to eat it like it's
no big deal so I think that was their
subtle way of visually telling us that
he's with the Church of blood even
though we haven't officially seen them
on the TV show yet it's just that
they're the primary organization trying
to worship Trigon and bring him to this
earth the reason why he's really
important for the Red Hood character is
is because throughout the episode they
take great links to explain how he's
really brainwashing normal people and
turning them into the nuclear family
members that we've met for the past
couple of episodes the creepy
terminators that they've been sending
after the Titans are actually real
humans that have just had their brains
scrambled they mess up he'll detonate
the explosive devices blow their heads
up and just replace them with another
newly brainwashed candidate so getting
to the Red Hood of it all Jason Todd
goes down in a fight in a future episode
they believe him to be dead the Titans
but secretly the Church of blood gets
their hands on him brainwash him and
sets him against the Titans that would
be the easiest most practical way to get
to Red Hood if they don't want to go
full Lazarus Pit Killing Joke because
even though they've started to do Batman
on the TV show I don't know if there are
any rules about them doing the Joker and
you can't really do Killing Joke without
doing the Joker and he's such a big
character we have the Joker movie coming
out next year it gets really confusing
when it comes to stuff like that like
how can you do Batman
but you can't technically do the Joker
we'll see about that
it's just that in mainstream continuity
Jason Todd got thrown in the Lazarus Pit
that's what brought him back to life and
the reason why he's crazy is is because
that's a side effect sometimes of the
Lazarus pits
people's minds just collapse when
they're brought back to life until the
bat family is eventually able to talk
him down like you actually spent a good
deal of time with the Red Hood character
when he was first introduced in the
comics with him going after Batman while
also trying to continue this mission of
cleaning up the city albeit in a crazy
brutal way so there's no way that they
would do Jason Todd on this TV show and
tease this dark future that he's headed
for if he doesn't leave Batman like Dick
Grayson keeps telling him you're headed
down a dark path but obviously that's
where he's going with Red Hood so we
know it's all going to come to fruition
if for some reason they are not able to
do the Joker on the TV show let me know
how you want them to do red hoods
origin story there are a couple minor
changes that I'm expecting because Jason
Todd's died when he was very young like
only just a little while after he became
Robin then when he was red hood and came
back he was much older so what they
might do is just sort of collapse that
timeline a little bit so the version of
red hood we see on the TV show could
just be like a little bit older I know
there are a lot of you comic book
readers that'll also point out that hive
was an organization tied to Deathstroke
that also brainwashed a lot of people
particularly Grant Wilson so a great
Wilson joins hive they juice him up with
a version of a Super Soldier Serum and
he starts going after the Titans and
Deathstroke tries to save him because
he's his son like you don't realize what
they're doing to you that's a whole big
thing that we can get to in a future
season because Geoff Johns did say that
they would eventually do a version of
Deathstroke they would probably do some
of the seminal Deathstroke comic book
arcs with the Teen Titans
so anything that you're really hoping
for they probably have plans to do it at
some point but what'll happen is is I
have some new Game of Thrones that I'm
working on there was also a funny Rick
and Morty promotion that happened
recently that I might do a video for I
know people have been wanting some Rick
and Morty season for updates so no
worries just leave all your video
requests in the comments below
but click here for my new Avengers 4
teaser video and click here for my brand
new flash trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight